[Music]
like many offices all over the country
my staff here at here at the show did a
Secret Santa gift exchange and usually I
don't get involved in those this year I
decided to participate I thought it'd be
fun right I got involved and
participated in our Secret Santa
exchange and for no good reason I filmed
the entire thing
let's take a look every year my staff
does Secret Santa I always hear about it
but I never participate my thought has
always been I give the gift of
employment you know I'm done
I've asked Jessica cope to join me
Jessica works on the staff as Andy
Richter's assistant yep Andy assistant
yes you draw name if you want to try
again you can draw up to three times
total but then you have to choose
someone out of those three people okay
all right all right ready no idea who
this is
is that someone who else should know
definitely
have I met this person have they been
with me a while
I've seen you speak to him before so so
this is this is the names and faces of
everybody who works here what I'll do is
I'll see a face I'll see a face and then
I recognize the person and I know them
I'll pick them okay okay okay that's me
yeah she's cute
yeah what if I just took her there's a
restaurant I know in Maui yeah and why
is that cool or is that considered she
might be dating someone yeah but I'm on
television yeah I know her I know her I
like her right this is my Secret Santa
okay so this stage done done perfect and
now let the fun begin
[Music]
okay this is really bad oh yeah
I blew this I have not done a thing
where's Ashley's desk where's Ashley's
desk which desk is it it's it's this one
Carrie you sit next to Ashley right okay
what does she like what kind of things
does she like is incense what's this all
about
okay it's not like she smokes a lot of
pot here and she's probably not okay all
right
do you smoke a lot of pot here and she's
covering up for you who's smoking pot
here okay we'll get that later you can't
say all right who's smoking pot here
okay
[Applause]
does you need sunglasses bases empty
okay those are expensive okay one add a
woman's vitamins my man that's creepy
here here's some estrogen supplements
that's not cool Oh looky here someone
likes John Hamm I don't get it myself I
guess to see this she liked John Hamm
does she love John Hamm what is it is it
it is he attractive really look at this
is he attracted to you now still
attractive to you that's not the answer
I wanted lead this way because it's more
dramatic on television this is both of
you but okay really sorry
okay I've got a late start but I think I
came up with an idea it is time now to
reveal myself to Ashley Olivia she
doesn't know anything about this as her
secret santa she doesn't know why she's
been brought backstage we have Ashley
come out here please and how are you I
got a late start but look what I got you
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
he's pretty you know what as too bad I
didn't get it signed let's take care of
that right now John
[Applause]
no no let me sign it there you go there
you go sir thank you so much for doing
this I called him like nine minutes ago
he wasn't even in the area we got a
helicopter to bring him here this is so
cool just writing a long speech there he
come that is so cool I did get one more
thing you did yeah I noticed you were
running low I got you some more
[Applause]